>> Laura: THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SWEARS IT IS
TAKING THE HAITIANS SITUATION
SERIOUSLY.
>> OUR BORDERS ARE NOT OPEN.
IF YOU COME TO THE UNITED STATES
ILLEGALLY YOU WILL BE RETURNED.
YOUR JOURNEY WON'T SUCCEED AND
YOU WILL ENDANGER YOUR LIFE AND
YOUR FAMILY'S LIFE.
>> Laura: NO ONE IS BUYING THAT.
THE ASSOCIATED PRESS REPORTED
THAT HAITIANS WERE FREED ON
A LARGE SCALE.
ONE U.S. OFFICIAL PUT THE FIGURE
IN THE THOUSANDS WITH NOTICES TO
APPEAR AT AN IMMIGRATION OFFICE
WITHIN 60 DAYS.
IT REQUIRES LESS PROCESSING
TIME.
HERE IS SENATOR TED CRUZ FROM
TEXAS.
THIS IS JUST SHEER LAWLESSNESS.
REPORTS THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS EVEN TRYING TO
GET A CONTRACTOR TO RUN
A FACILITY IN GITMO TO HOLD SOME
OF THE OVERFLOW.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE?
>> WELL, WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
DEL RIO ILLUSTRATES THE CAUSE
AND EFFECT OF OF THE BIDEN
BORDER DISASTER.
ON SEPTEMBER 8th UNDER THAT
BRIDGE THERE WERE BETWEEN 700
AND 1,000 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
MOSTLY FROM HAITI.
THAT HAD BEEN THE CONSISTENT
FLOW.
700 TO 1,000 A DAY CROSSING
ILLEGALLY AT THAT POINT.
ON SEPTEMBER 8th THERE WERE 900
HAITIANS SCHEDULE TO BE ON
AIRPLANES TO GO BACK TO HAITI.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CANCELLED THOSE FLIGHTS.
WE WON'T DEPORT YOU.
YOU CAN STAY HERE AND REMAIN IN
AMERICA.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS SIMPLE.
THOSE 900 HAITIANS THEY PULLED
OUT THEIR PHONES.
THEY CALLED THEIR FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS.
YOU HAD 700 PEOPLE ON SEPTEMBER
8th.
I WAS DOWN IN DEL RIO 8 DAYS
LATER ON SEPTEMBER 16th.
THE DAY I WAS THERE, 700 PEOPLE
HAD BECOME 10,503.
IT TOOK 8 DAYS FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN.
THAT 10,000 BECAME 15,000.
IT WAS STRAIGHT CAUSE AND
EFFECT.
THE WORD WENT OUT THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WON'T ENFORCE THE
LAW.
IF YOU ARE FROM HAITI COME TO
DEL RIO BECAUSE YOU GET TO STAY.
THAT PRODUCED THIS DISASTER.
>> Laura: SENATOR, WHAT CAN THE
SENATE DO AT THIS POINT?
PEOPLE COME UP TO ME AND I KNOW
THEY COME UP TO YOU AND SAY, IS
THERE NOTHING WE CAN DO?
THIS IS A PURPOSEFUL
RESETTLEMENT OF MILLIONS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
IS THE ONLY THING WE CAN DO IS
AN ELECTION?
>> THE SENATE COULD DO A GREAT
DEAL.
BUT WE ARE NOT GOING TO BECAUSE
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE DEMOCRAT
WHO WILL WORK WITH US TO SECURE
THE BORDER.
EVERY DEMOCRAT, TODAY'S
DEMOCRATS ARE THE PARTY OF OPEN
BORDERS.
THE LAST FEW WEEKS I TRAVELED
ALONG SOUTH TEXAS.
NOT JUST IN DEL RIO.
I WAS IN McALLEN AND ROMA AND I
DID ROUND TABLES WITH RANCHERS
AND FARMERS AND SHERIFFS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
MOST THE LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
IN SOUTH TEXAS ARE DEMOCRATS.
IT'S A DEMOCRATIC AREA OF THE
STATE.
EVERY ELECTED DEMOCRAT I MET
WITH WAS SO HORRIFIED BY WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER.
THEY SAID IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS THE PARTY OF OPEN
BORDERS COUNT ME OUT.
I CAN'T SUPPORT.
THIS.
IT'S AN UNFOLDING DISASTER.
IN TODAY IN WASHINGTON NOT
A SINGLE DEMOCRAT CARES.
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS
WON'T GO DOWN TO THE BORDER THE
RIO GRANDE VALLEY OR DEL RIO.
THEY INSIST THESE PROBLEMS ARE
NOT HAPPENING.
WE ARE AT 2 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
WE ARE ON THE PATH TO MORE.
AS LONG AS JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA
HARRIS REFUSE TO APPLY THE LAW
IT IT WILL GET WORSE.
>> Laura: AND ONLY 13% FROM THE
REPORT IN JULY OF THE 50,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THEY LOOKED
AT WITH A COURT DATE EVEN SHOW
UP.
ONCE THEY ARE HERE AND THEY ARE
RESETTLED INTO THE UNITED
STATES, THEY ARE NOT COMING
BACK.
THOSE ARE NEW WORKERS OR PEOPLE
WHO ARE GIG GETTING BENEFITS IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND HEALTHCARE --
DO WE KNOW HOW MUCH THIS IS
COSTING THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA?
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
THE COSTS ARE MASSIVE OF HOUSING
AND TRANSPORTING THEM.
MANY TURN THEMSELVES INTO THE
JORDAN PATROL AND JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS ARE THE LAST MILE
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND BRING
THEM TO THEIR FINAL DESTINATION.
WHEN I DID THE ROUND TABLES IN
SOUTH TEXAS, ONE THING WE SAW
ARE THE COLOR-CODED WRISTBANDS